[Music]
this is Chris Pratt we're at the GQ
photo shoot for mana here is the man of
the year man of the year
oh no way hey what's up on the night of
the year who would I nominate for man of
the year Russell Wilson Richard Sherman
the entire roster the Seattle Seahawks
maybe Pete Carroll - woman of the year
well I better say my wife yeah hi my
wife my song of the year would have to
be everything is awesome from the lego
movie really rings true definitely in
this moment right now movie of the year
via tie between two of the greatest
masterpieces in the history of cinema
one would be the lego movie and the
other would be Marvel's guardians of the
galaxy both of those movies I just
really love them no no no I really they
are really truly my two favorite movies
of the year I happen to be in them yes
that's me but usually that means I like
something less funniest person of the
year that's the tough man I think I'd be
remiss not to say Robin Williams or Joan
Rivers also funniest person of the Year
villain of the year but basically anyone
in the San Francisco 49ers Jersey Colin
Kaepernick is probably the villain of
the year this is the greatest year in my
life the Seattle Seahawks wanted to pull
I don't really have a favorite dance
move of the year I've been doing the
same dance moves since 1994 which is the
running man my favorite moment of the
year was probably like approaching the
stage to do my monologue breaths now
that was pretty wild I'm happy to say I
spent most of this you're working that's
what I was doing that's the activity I
did the most this year I probably about
46,000 chickens this year just nothing
but chicken chicken chicken chicken for
me it's all about good protein I just
cook it grill it no skin the biggest
waste of time this interview so far it's
been this
no probably a Twitter hundred Twitter
and online ship just looking away I just
looking at my phone one word this year
seismic
[Music]